wimbledon with its green grass red
strawberries and all-white dress code
for players can be an escape from the
world's turmoil not this year the
biggest stars are playing but not the
russians to blunt the propaganda
benefits that vladimir putin and russia
derive from their international sports
figures wimbledon has banned players
from russia and belarus government
industry sport and creative institutions
are all playing their part in efforts to
limit russia's global influence but the
men's and women's tennis tours opposed
the move believing individual players
should not be targeted so they stripped
wimbledon of the points normally awarded
from the tournament my honest opinion i
think it's i don't think it
was a good idea to ban the russian
players to play i think medvedev is the
best we have in our sport right now
daniel medvedev is the top-ranked men's
player in the world he's not at
wimbledon but like many russian athletes
is careful about criticizing russia or
the measures to punish russia i always
say that i have to follow the rules
and where i can play i'm going to play
i'm going to try to play my best
russians can play at the upcoming u.s
and canadian opens ukrainian player
elena's vitilino wants greater support
from sport's governing bodies our sports
is thrown back
by 10 years
minimum
because
all the all the
infrastructure been damaged or
completely destroyed
one academic says international sports
cannot divorce politics from sports and
have failed when trying to be neutral in
trying to maintain neutrality uh it
really played into putin's hands the
institutions the organizations that put
on these events
have to be cognizant of international
affairs the nhl is one international
league that did not look to ban russians
such as alex ovechkin who opposes the
war but has openly supported vladimir
putin for the lone russian on the
champion colorado avalanche there is one
setback valerie nachoskin will not be
allowed to take the stanley cup and show
it off back in russia as his countrymen
have done in the past eric sorensen
global news toronto